in the United States 13 out of every 20
cans are recycled what percent of cans
are recycled so 13 out of every 20 are
recycled so 13 20 it's or 13 over 20
could also be viewed as 13 13 divided by
20 or 13 divided by divided by 20 and if
we do this we'll get a decimal and it's
fairly straightforward to convert that
decimal into a percentage so 13/20 we
have the smaller number in this case
being divided by the larger number so
we're going to get a value less than one
since we're going to get a let value
less than one let's put a decimal right
over here and let's add a couple of
zeros as many zeros as we would need and
we could say hey look 20 goes into 13
zero times zero times 20 is zero and
then 13 minus zero is 13 now you bring
down a zero 20 goes into 130 let's see
it goes in five times 20 is 100 so 6
times 20 is 120 this is going to go 6
times 6 times 20 is 120 you subtract you
get a 10 let's bring down another zero
20 goes into 100 five times 5 times 20
is 100 and we are we are done so this
written as a decimal this written as a
decimal is 0.65 so as a decimal it's
0.65 and if you want to write it as a
percentage you essentially multiply this
by 100 or another way you could say is
you shift the decimal over two spots to
the right so this is going to be equal
to 65 65 percent now there's another way
you could have done it is you could have
said look percent literally means per
hundred
so 13 out of 20 13 out of 20 is going to
be equal to what over is going to be
equal to what over 100 well to go from
20 to 100 you forget the denominator to
go from 20 to 100 you would multiply
by five so let's multiply the numerator
by five as well and thirteen times five
let's see that's 15 plus 50 which is 65
so this would have been a little bit of
fat a faster way to do it especially if
you recognize it's pretty easy to go
from 20 to 100 you multiply by 5 so we
do the same thing with the 13 and so
you'd get 65 over 100 which is the same
thing as 65 / let me write this percent
symbol 65% and it's a reminder percent
literally means per hundred sixty-five
per hundred sixty-five percent